what you can't do is devalue yourself or
your attention in any way
what what happens now in the modern
world is that men's attention no longer
has value
in the 1950s and 60s if a girl got the
attention of a good looking guy it mean
it meant something because how many
times can she get the attention of a
good looking guy she walks down the
street whatever in the world of
instagram and facebook and social media
a girl's getting blown up so what what
does your attention have your attention
has no value so the the way you give it
value is one becoming a higher value man
but another way you have to make sure
your attention has values you don't
throw it away because it suffers from
inflation like anything else and this is
how you end up with guys who are buying
presents taking girls on holiday doing
everything for them but their attention
is so low value that it means less than
one text from me after three months
being smart being witty all these things
help but this is the reality of life as
a man is that you have to build your
value
people say to me all the time oh yeah
you get girls i said i got girls because
i became a kickboxing world champion
that's thousands of hours in the gym i
didn't i wasn't born with something
magic i mean i wasn't born with some
tool you know i was like
i had to do it myself so you have to
build it as a man this is just
unfortunate reality if you're if you're
not prepared to do any work at all
you're gonna suffer so you can't hack
you can't hack having a personality you
can't trick a girl into thinking you're
something you're not if you want a woman
to really respect you then be a man
worthy of respect
it's really that simple and on top of
that one of the easiest ways to be a man
worthy of respect is to refuse to take
disrespect you can be nice to women i'm
not saying don't be nice the idea of
being nice in and of itself has no value
because nice is something which is
intangible nice is something that can be
fabricated right here i can go out there
be nice we can be nice to people we
don't like anybody can be nice so if
there's no skirt there's no scarcity
attached how can i have a value
something like status is very hard to
fake right something like that lambo is
very hard to think all these things are
very hard to fake but nice can be faked
but the point is when a guy comes along
trying to be nice i think women
instinctively kind of look at you and go
look you just met me you don't know me
and you're being extremely nice to me
and that to a degree i think warns them
that's that's deceptive on some level i
think that's the reason they're semi
repulsed by it like you knew me an hour
ago and you're being all nice to me like
what do you want well we know what we
want and she knows what we want yeah so
the whole thing just looks fake it
doesn't look genuine and integrity and
and being a genuine person is not just
something that women respected men it's
something that people respect in other
people so it's good when a woman meets
you to know you're a genuine individual
i'm a nice guy there's a huge advantage
in life to being likable that is a skill
that most people should cultivate being
likable in the real world the people who
dislike me are people i've decided it's
okay for me to dislike
or pure violent haters if every man gets
right but if i'm in a conversation with
somebody and i want them to like me i
have 100 success rate i know how to make
people like i know how to be a likable
person
the only resource you have is your
attention and the reason it's so
difficult is because now women get so
much attention for no reason then why
does your attention have value you have
to put value on your attention so then
how do you put value on your attention
what did we talk earlier about how
trauma can mold you now trauma could be
a fantastic thing
heartbreak
depression sadness these are all
fantastic motivators you're just i'm
telling you why they're a fantastic
motivator you go to a guy who's
heartbroken he has all the motivation in
the world to send 300 text messages
he has the motivation he's putting it in
the wrong place that's 300 cold emails
you could be sending a picture a lot of
money you could have made
life's gonna hurt you and how you use
that pain is completely not really up to
you you can use that pain to galvanize
yourself as a man and become a better
man you've ever been i'm not saying that
i'm only successful because of some
chick i'm saying that every single time
that i was heartbroken i never wasted a
second i was never wallowing that's what
i'm saying true trauma's going to
complain to the common you have to use
it in a constructive way
i'm not telling you to tell him to avoid
the pain i'm saying that when it comes
make sure it's used in a constructive
way and still to this day that's all i
would ever do if something bad happened
to me and i got really upset i would
find the most constructive possible
outlet that's a conscious decision you
have to have the emotional control to
make a conscious decision
but i think another side of it is you
just need to be also you need to be
uncompromising and you need to be
uncompromising in a very positive way so
i like i always say to people i've never
been in the friend zone in my life and
the reason i've never been in the friend
zone in my life is because i'm very
clear about my intentions
i think you're beautiful
oh we're friends or no we're not so are
you coming on a date with me or not no
okay good goodbye and i think that a lot
of the biggest mistakes guys make is
they they don't believe they can be
affirmative as a man without coming
across as an [ __ ] or coming across as
a jerk or coming across creepy you can
be just be affirmative than who you are
be confident with who you are and be
clear about your intentions and you'll
be fine so don't be trying too hard now
the reason i get away with such little
work is because i put such a high price
tag on myself
i am a four-time kickboxing world
champion multi-millionaire
so even eve any female no matter how
beautiful knows i'm never gonna be the
guy hitting her up constantly i'm not
gonna be the guy she can call and i'll
always answer i'm not gonna be the dude
who will give her lifts to work she
knows i got [ __ ] going on remember what
i was saying earlier to you about how
i've never struggled with females
because i never focused on the females
these other game books and roosh and all
these idiots
worry about yourself get yourself
straight
and when your own shit's straight you've
got yourself together females are an
added bonus
if you go up to a thousand girls you get
five phone numbers and one might [ __ ]
you yeah i'm sure that's absolutely true
but so
you're gonna spend your life instead of
becoming rich instead of becoming strong
instead of becoming smart you're just
gonna [ __ ] run around a mall
approaching girls day game
it's garbage for children all that is
for children i focused on myself
and that's how i've managed to attain
the highest quality females and also not
attain
retain and sometimes that's difficult
let me tell you something she might be
talking to a real g if she's talking to
me
you're gonna struggle to make her like
you more that's true i have more
tangible assets
more physical financial and mental
assets plus i know the game
sometimes you're out class that's how it
goes sometimes you're just out class
that's how it goes it's another thing
you can't really control but what you
can control in those situations is that
you don't make her lose respect for you
keep your honor about you if you're
gonna lose the game there's two ways to
lose it with honor and without honor
so you have to have a system in place
that's going to allow you to escalate
and elevate your conversations and
elevate and escalate your
relationship and her interest level in
you if you're going to sit there and
just message girls you might be on
lockdown for the next six weeks how are
you every day how are you fine you what
are you doing at home you home
so you go you gotta have a little bit
more strategy than that you know what i
mean but then you have to understand
you're always in competition with other
dudes if a girl is messaging you that
she's in 20
so why does she like you and not the
rest i mean it's not easy as a man
nowadays it's really not easy as a man
it's getting harder and harder i'm not
saying that you you can't get hot girls
i'm just saying that the hot girls are
certainly aware of their worth and
instagram gives them unlimited dating
pool like yeah one of my girls has 69
000 followers on instagram her instagram
account's on my phone so i can see
anytime and she gets a message every
six minutes maybe
and she's had messages from verified nfl
stars chicago bulls all this
so like if you're a hawk girl like if
you ever feel lonely you click your
instagram inbox you scroll through
and you decide who you want to reply to
yeah like these girls are never lonely
and they're never not talking to someone
and this is the element that most men
forget and this is something i try and
drive home in the phd course the reason
it's so hard for a man is you're not
trying to make her like you
you're trying to make her like you more
than she likes the guy she was talking
to before you
yeah so you're always in competition all
the time
and the competition as a man is near
unlimited and that's something you have
to keep in mind you have to be on the
ball and you have to be ruthless with it
you go have your game in check
[Music]
and you can get to a point where if
you're really smooth with it it gets
easy